In today's video,
we are tackling
a project inspired by
the artist Greg Klassen,
making a small end table
out of a piece of burl wood log.
[Music]
Today's video is going to look
a little bit differently,
because instead of
having my camera guy,
Mark film everything,
this is actually just something
I'm doing on my own time.
So it's just being filmed
on my cell phone.
I do have a spare mic,
so I'm using that.
But it's mostly just going to be
single camera angle at a time,
and we'll see if we
can make it look good.
All right, I've got
this big ol log here,
which has got
some lovely burl's on it.
Burl is basically
when the tree gets
sort of a tumor,
and you can see we've got
a couple of them right here.
One of them right here.
This is what we're going to be
using to make most of the table.
First thing I need
to do is cut this.
What I want to do
is get one piece,
maybe inch and a half,
two inches wide,
that comes down through both
of these pieces
of burl right here,
and then a second piece
that I'm going to cut
out this direction,
that comes down
through this piece of burl.
I have drawn onto the top
of it some lines.
That's about where I want
that first cut to go.
So I'll cut here and here.
Then I'll have
this half of the log,
and then I'll cut that direction
from what's left to try and get
this strip right there.
I'm going to try and secure it
to the table as best I can.
It's going to be
a little messy, probably.
[Music]
Beautiful.
Cut it open.
Now, I just have to do
that like three more times.
So more trimming will be done.
Generally, I'll just trim
off kind of along this part.
Little bit around here,
and probably right around there.
Just a nice little rectangle.
Now, I need to clean these off.
They're not very even.
I just cut them with
a hand saw, obviously,
and so, they need some planing work.
I don't actually feel
like these pieces
need to be 100% level
and even all the way through.
If there's a little bit
of fluctuation that's
not too much of a problem,
it's not going to be sitting
on a flat base.
I'm just going to build a frame
that goes around parts
of the edge of it.
And so,
if there's some wonkiness
going on in there,
it's not really a problem.
I think it will
actually add to the,
to the live edge look of it.
Obviously though.
I want it flat enough
that, you know,
I can set a cup down on it,
and not have it tip over,
stuff like that.
Mostly for this,
I think I'm just going to be
using a handheld belt sander,
and see how it looks after that.
[Music]
That is already bringing
out some brilliant figuring,
and that's like 80 grit.
This stuff is going
to look so good
when it's all polished up.
Next step is to sand blast
the end pieces of the wood.
I'm here with my friend Dennis,
who is letting me use
his sandblasting kit,
because I don't have
one of those,
and it's a pretty nifty set up.
So we've got sand
that fits in that thing there.
It feeds through here.
The blue hose has
the compressed air.
It pulls all
the sand out with it,
and it just--
It's like sandpaper
without the paper part.
It just starts tearing
stuff down, which is great,
because these edges
are not really an area I
can get sandpaper down into.
I even tried a little bit
with steel wool,
and there's just too
many nooks and crannies.
But sandblasting works great.
Not breathe in sand
or wood dust,
and let's not get
it in our eyes.
What?
[Music]
Beautiful.
Look at that.
That is so much cleaner
than it was before.
That's just--
That is fantastic.
[Music]
That worked great.
This wood is so soft
that I'm able to cut even
through like a 2-inch plank
of it with no problem.
So we're just going
to keep doing that.
Now, one other little thing
I want to do right here,
I have kind of a large cavity,
and that's not
necessarily a problem.
But I think we could make it
a little bit more interesting.
We've got some extra
pieces of the wood,
including some that have some
of this nice burl on it.
So I think we're going
to try and cut a piece
that can sit right here as sort
of just an extra little island.
[Music]
I think that's a great fit
for that piece right there.
So now, I need to trim it this way,
and then flatten it off just a little bit,
and I think we can use
this saw for that again.
[Music]
So we've built the box.
You can see that the wood
fits nicely into it.
On the back,
we're going for pretty much
flush up against the wall,
but on the sides, you can see
we are leaving a gap.
Now, we'll trim
down the blackboard.
It'll have a little bit
of extra space going all
around the border.
That's all right.
Well, then flip
the white frame over,
and we'll attach the black part
of the frame onto the white
part of the frame,
then we should have our box.
[Music]
Also, just to make sure
that none of the resin
tries to escape,
I'm gonna seal up all of
the gaps with electrical tape.
There is a little bit more prep
work we need to do on our box.
We first actually want
to give that a coat of wax.
Hopefully, that will make it
so the resin doesn't stick
to it very much,
so we can then peel
the box pieces off later on.
[Music]
You know, before I
clamp these on,
I want to cover
the clamps with something
so that resin doesn't spill out,
and just get all over those.
So I'm gonna use
a little bit of foil
or plastic wrapped around those,
just to not ruin them.
Now, when the resin flows,
the wood will not float
on top of it.
We're going to be doing
the resin pour indoors,
because it's not good
if you let it get
too hot or too cold.
So a nice climate
controlled environment is good.
However, you also don't want
to be breathing it in.
First step, we need
to pour off some
of both types of resin into
our smaller mixing containers.
We'll then pour 1/2
into the other one.
For coloring,
we'll be using this alcohol
ink sailboat blue color.
Mix it up for a while,
then pour that into
our larger bucket,
and our larger bucket will go
into our vacuum chamber.
It will suck out all of the air,
so there's not bubbles
left in the resin,
and then, it'll get poured
into the table.
[Music]
No bubbles.
Coming back after
the second pour,
and it's looking good
over most of it.
But unfortunately,
we do have one spot
where the resin cracked.
You can see
that crack extending
all the way down
through that second pour layer,
and I think it
actually even goes down
into the first pour layer,
a little bit down in there.
It split right across,
and maybe this is because I
poured too thick of a layer.
May be the first
layer was still warm,
and the interaction
between the two layers
was too much for it.
But let's mix up a third pour.
We're not going to use
nearly all of it.
We're just going to try
and get it high enough
that it comes up to the level
of the wood everywhere.
Maybe overflowing just
the tiniest bit.
Fill some of these gaps.
[Music]
This all filled in quite nicely.
There's a lot
of resin in that gap.
So I think on this side,
it is full enough.
We've got other spots
that may not have enough yet.
This one over here
didn't feel quite as well.
We'll cut off the other
side and see how it is.
[Music]
We are going to take this edge,
and give it a pass
right along this.
[Music]
Perfect.
This side of the table
is really the one
that has all of the cracks
that need filling.
The other side did pretty good.
This one's just got a few spots,
few cracks that didn't
feel quite enough.
The other side
actually did have some,
it looked like.
When I planed the edge off,
they went away.
So they were really shallow.
So we're just going
to mix up some resin
with no coloring in it,
and then we're going
to use a pipette,
and fill right down
into these cracks.
[Music]
The surface of our table
is pretty much all
prepped and ready.
But what I need to do now is put
a couple more layers of resin
over all of this.
So I'm going to do one layer
just pour it over all of that,
and that should pretty much
seal up the woods,
so it stops soaking it in.
After that layer is cured,
I'll do a really clean up
work that I need to,
removing drips off the edge,
and maybe a little
bit of sanding,
but then I'll do one more layer
of resin on top of that,
and at that point,
it should all just be a glossy
clear perfectly smooth surface.
[Music]
The frame for our table
is going to be made
of these simple pieces of metal
that I'm just grabbing
at the hardware store.
They're not too expensive.
We're going to do
a little bit of grinding,
a little bit of welding,
and a little bit of painting,
and we'll have our frame.
[Music]
Our metal pieces are cut,
welded, shaped and painted,
and we've now got our frame.
It's fairly minimalistic,
but I really want the top
of this table to be the focus.
We have now finished this table.
The frame is built.
It's attached, it's
sitting on here.
You are still able
to lift it up.
But the friction from
these little sponge rubber pads
on the sides does a pretty
good job of holding it in place.
I'm quite happy with
how stable it is.
I'm very happy
with how it looks.
There are imperfections,
and of course, things I
would probably do differently
if I were making a second one.
Overall, I am quite happy
with how the surface
of this table turned out.
I love that just incredible
wood grain that's visible
through the resin.
I'm very happy
with the result on that.
So this has been
a really cool project,
and I'm excited to have
this set up in my place
as a sort of combination
functional table art piece.
That's going to be exciting.
That's not all though.
You know, we've always
got more for you see.
That box up at the top
is going to take you directly
to our last video.
You should go check that out.
The other box
is going to show you
what YouTube thinks you
should be watching next.
If you hit this bomb the middle,
you'll be subscribe
to the channel.
That way, you
never miss a video.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we'll see you the next one.
Talk to you then.